you guys have any
company no his dumbass coach just
started calling this play plays more
because there's number more
but no you know he and I have talked and
I told him I'm a force feeding man and
just be aggressive don't worry about it
just be aggressive going to the rim and
he did that tonight you know he had a
Swagger about him
he wasn't settling you know he's one of
the best mid-range Shooters I've ever
been around more than capable of
knocking down threes but again he was
loving and living in the paint tonight
that's the A.D we need that's the ad
that's gonna that aggression and him
forcing uh his will forcing them to
knowing they can't guard him to file him
um it speeds up the process of us giving
to the bonus and that helps everyone
else so now it's a block and file out on
the perimeter Austin gets to go to the
free throw line Delo Dennis these these
guys and they've been struggling a
little bit with their jump shot they get
to see a couple go in hopefully we
missed 10 free throws tonight but uh
hopefully they get to see their shot go
in and it helps boost their confidence
and it just has a ripple effect up and
down the roster
a